we've got the standard Lucinda
neighborhood
each team yeah he's teaching burning
stuff he's an honors teacher - no
that's our extracurricular musical
energy
yeah
Masek music occupied you seen the place
well Jesus but this time last year she
was Pirates of the Caribbean
the guy who's a concert pianist got ups
two-minute warning before the briefing -
that water
hello everyone I hope you all had an
enjoyable weekend I have some brief
announcements for you today just that
now we have 760 sites in retail
locations in 45 states plus the District
of Columbia CVS is planning to open an
additional 650 sites since these are
encouraging numbers it's again a
testament to our private sector for all
that they've done and partnering with
the administration and helping to stop
the spread of the corona virus also
skilled nursing facilities there was an
announcement that I just want to
underscore that 4.9 billion in
additional relief funds were distributed
to nursing homes and other skilled
nursing facilities and these funds are
provided under the cares Act so just
those two items for you this morning and
we'll go ahead and we'll start with
questions John China is making more
sending more overtures that it will
crack down on Hongkong what's the
message from the administration to the
Chinese government about changing the
special status at one o'clock yeah and I
know Jen I you also emailed a question
about this this morning so I went
directly to the president to get an
answer on this and he said to me that
he's displeased with China's efforts and
that it's hard to see how Hong Kong can
remain a financial hub if China takes
over the United States change its
relationship with Hong Kong so I have no
further announcements as to the precise
action that the president will be taking
but he did want me to share that with
you this morning this afternoon I should
say yes probably much older I realize
now we saw a lot of images over at the
memorial
again a people gathering and large
crowds not maintaining social distancing
this images as for the lake of the
ozarks in the survey was one example we
saw all over television news for the
president have any concerns about those
kinds of gatherings we haven't heard any
message from him addressing best well
the president as he's noted he wants to
see society reopen wants to see the
economy reopen but we do want to do so
safely and there are institutions that
have put into place these social
distancing measures and people are
making it cognizant a part of their
everyday lives for me for example I went
to Mass this weekend and people were
socially distant they were washing their
hands there are ways to do this and the
president went underscore to everyone
that we should be taken into account
these measures so yes everyone while you
go out let's keep cognizant the
recommendations of the CDC because those
on demand are very important to making
sure that there is no spread of the
virus and I would just also note one
point I did have some updated numbers
for you on reopening and what we're
seeing across the country that I think
are important that 42 states are now
under 10 percent in their positivity
rate for the virus mortality is now
equivalent to what we saw at the end of
March that's the lowest level in two
months so we are seeing these
encouraging signs as we start to reopen
which seem to be criticizing Joe Biden
for wearing a mask
was that as a tetraman if it was why
would you criticize that I think look
you know the president's excited to see
that Joe emerged from the basement it is
a bit peculiar though that in his
basement right next to his wife he's not
wearing a mask but he's wearing one on
what outdoors when he's socially distant
so I think that there was a discrepancy
there he's not shaming anyone as the
president noted himself he wore this
mask in private on at the Ford facility
and he said he's open to it if the
circumstance mandates it the guy is to
wear a mask outside it's recommended but
not required so it's the personal choice
of the individual but it didn't strike
him as a very data-driven decision in
that particular incident yes Peter if we
can just do a little housekeeping first
we know Katie Miller Smith is back at
work today is the White House that lady
back at work and has anybody else within
the White House complex tested positive
for the virus besides those two
individuals and we learned about a
couple weeks ago so I don't know about
the valet I haven't inquired about that
no updates as to who's tested positive
or not that's not something I regularly
keep tabs on but Katie Miller is back at
work we're very happy to see her
recovered I spoke to her yesterday I
haven't seen her today but she did have
several negative test results before she
ran toward the building let us know of
anybody else people are worried about
the president's safety the vice
president's can you let us know that
nobody else has tested positive in the
two-plus weeks that have now passed
since those cases I can inquire about
events people's personal medical
decisions so I'm not entirely sure that
that would be given to me but if I can
the president and a tweet earlier today
said that he's made governor's look very
good by getting them what he said was
unlimited testing that's not true you've
said that it's not even necessary so why
is the president saying that he's saying
what he means by that is that the
governor has requested a specific amount
of testing to reopen and he indeed has
provided that us that's the test and you
would agree it is what they asked for in
phase one it's the full panoply of what
every governor asked for that was given
to him I've given to them and it's 300
to 400 thousand tests per day that we're
doing that's a really good number I did
talk to Admiral wah before coming out
here and the metric that appear to
believe the w-h-o I don't particularly
these days but they say it's a good
barometer of testing is 10 percent
positivity or under an Admiral's law
shared with me that
nationally at 7.5% so we're in a pretty
good spot Stephen Miller yes I just saw
him on an outer oval so he is back in at
work takes him some time away from the
White House though for a while he did he
did he self quarantined with his wife
but they're both back at work and
healthy and happy and we're very happy
to see them around fine
at the Pentagon the the top watchdog
over at the Pentagon met he submitted
his resignation today can you say if
that was encouraged didn't even ask him
and can you talk about the importance
about those internal watchdogs that are
in our government agencies so we you
said it was Glenn fine
that was that's the first that I'm
hearing about this but with regards to
the other IGS I would note that the
president's within his authority his
legal and executive authority to appoint
new IGS and he said I think last week at
some point that it's within the
decision-making process of each entity
the State Department each department
whether to keep their IG or not and I
would note that President Obama has a
precedent of firing IGS as well and
there were in fact 47 IGS that signed a
letter claiming the Obama administration
hindered their efforts so there this is
not without precedent on when it comes
to IGS yes no matter what the kovat
infection rate is by late August the
president wants to see the convention
take place on he's noted that and he
wants to have a cooperative governor and
making that pursuit happen
that being said of course we always
assess the facts on the ground at any
time but at this moment the president
wants to see this convention take place
and sees no reason not to as the nation
begins to reopen nificant spike in the
cases he would be open to the idea of a
virtual convention understanding
couldn't be a traditional convention so
I won't engage on a hypothetical as to
where the cases will be but I would just
note that we assess the facts on a
day-by-day basis and currently we're
coming down on and that's really
encouraging to see and we're ready for
the convention to take place yes widower
sense to Jack Dorsey Twitter CEO seeing
that his tweets were emotionally
traumatic for him and for his excavator
his wife's family I don't know if he's
seen the letter
but I do know that our hearts are with
Laurie's family at this time the
president found in allegations this
isn't the president's accusing somebody
of possible murder the family is
pleading with the president to please
stop founded conspiracy theories why is
he doing it well you know I would note
that the president said this morning
that this is not an original Trump
thoughts on and it is not in fact 2003
on Don Imus his show it was Don Imus and
joe scarborough that joked about killing
an intern joked and laughed about it so
that was I'm sure pretty hurtful to
Laurie's family and Joe Scarborough
himself brought this up with Don Imus
and Joe Scarborough himself the United
States and he's accusing somebody of
possibly murder this is different he's
he's not a private citizen he's the
president and Joe Scarborough if we want
to start talking about false accusations
we have quite a few we can go through
about mica asserting lied to you and
saying this morning as recently I
believe was this morning or yesterday
mica accused the president of being
responsible for a hundred thousand
deaths in this country that's incredibly
irresponsible they've dragged his family
through the mud they've made false
accusations that I won't go through that
I would not say from this podium against
the President of the United States and
they should be held to account for their
falsehoods Joe Scarborough should be
held to account for saying people will
die by taking hydroxychloroquine never
mind the millions of Americans and
people across the world who take it for
rheumatory arthritis and other reasons
there are a litany of false headlines
like mica Freddie false
Spira C theory the security wait he's
actual for murder I would point you back
to Joe Scarborough who laughed and joked
about this item on Don Imus the show
it's Joe Scarborough that has to answer
these questions Stephen Stephen director
today because the president decided what
what's next for him he hasn't but brick
Grinnell is a very valued member of this
administration he's done extraordinary
work at odni he has a great history
we'll see where he goes next but just
know that Rick Grinnell has done an
excellent job in opposition I expect
that John Radcliffe will honest he takes
over biases reform and obviously it's
biases something he cares a lot of
balance now but he told me that he had
left it up to the Senators to figure out
and you know it's still ongoing this
process the house has to pass the
legislation that the Senate passed
Senate Senators tried and failed by just
one vote to ban the word elections
internet records so I'm wondering out
how the president you could describe a
little more how the president sees
himself this part of this debate and
whether he might intervene at some point
going forward it's very personal to the
president when it comes with fight comes
to FISA this is an important tool in the
intelligence community he knows that but
he also knows that it was used and
abused and politicized the fact that you
had 29 members of the Obama
administration third 29 individuals of
Intel community and Obama administration
unmasking dozens of times using these
tools that are so much power to spy on
an American citizen to listen to their
phone calls to unmask their names we
have a fourth amendment in this country
it protects the rights of Americans but
the rights were not protected when it
came to President Trump and his
administration and Michael Flynn whose
name was leaked in a criminal fashion to
the press FISA was not used
appropriately on a steel dossier full of
lies
that was quote salacious and unverified
in the words of Jim Comey was used as
the basis to get a FISA warrant and
attested to as if it were truthful you
know reason to spy on Carter page these
tools were used in abuse the Fourth
Amendment right
if several Americans were violated a
political campaign was spied upon so any
FISA concerns the president has they're
real they're personal and they should be
considered as we move forward to
reauthorize this valuable tool Brunel is
one of his last official acts at the
request of Adam Schiff Declassified
transcripts of the phone calls between
General Michael Flynn and Sergey and
kiss later would president Trump
encouraged John Ratcliffe to facilitate
the release of those transcripts I
haven't spoken to him on that but this
president has released not the president
rather but this president has overseen
an OD and I that has given the American
people a lot of information that I think
they're entitled to see and one of the
things the president has asked for is
where the 302s the summaries of that
interview with Michael Flynn 302s so the
American people understand these are
summaries when you interview an
individual and it's routine that those
302s are given in short order right
after the interview is done it's when
your memory is at its best but in the
case of Michael Flynn those 302s were
lost and in fact edited afterwards by
corrupt Peter struck and Lisa page us
there's a lot of questions and this
president has encouraged transparency on
this issue and I think it's a great
thing since of the 302s would he
encouraged the release of the transcript
so that the American people can see
exactly what transpired during this con
I haven't asked tonight I have to ask
them that particular question yes let me
get a few people in the back so I want
to make sure equal-opportunity question
caller so yes oh we're about two across
300,000
yeah American wild still what what does
the White House view as having by
Election Day what does the White House
view as the number of dead Americans
where you can say that we successfully
defeated this pandemic is there a number
yeah you know every loss of life counts
we say 100,000 but like the president
says you know one death is something to
be more and these a hundred thousand
individuals have a face the president
takes this very seriously it's why he
lowered the flag to half-staff for three
days to remember these men and women I
think you know dr. Burks said it best
when she said that and their estimates
they had anywhere between 1.5 and 2.2
million people in the u.s. succumbing to
the virus if we didn't shut down the
economy the president made the very hard
choice of shutting down the economy so
we avoided that extraordinary number
every one death is too many we've never
want to see a single individual lose
their life but that being said to be
under significantly that high mark shows
that the President did everything in his
power and helped to make this number as
low as humanly possible and they want to
judge the president when his response to
this pandemic what is the number of dead
Americans that they should tolerate as
happen and where they can argue that yes
he successfully competed I think you
know you're asking the wrong question
the right question is where did weird
data and I answered your question once
but if you ask it twice it doesn't make
it any better of a question so I'll
respond in kind I've given you one
answer I'll continue to extrapolate upon
that that he always listened to the
science the president when dr. Fauci and
dr. Burke said you need to shut down the
economy it was hard for the president
you know in a typical year 120,000
people die of suicide and drug overdose
it's in a typical year and doctors have
said when you shut down an economy for
an extended period of time that number
gets greater people don't show up for
their cancer diagnosis are there a
litany of results when you close down in
an economy but closing down the economy
for this amount of time kept us far
below to 2.2 million number as we start
to reopen we keep in mind the people who
are missing their screening appointments
the people who are not who are
succumbing to suicide and drug
because of economic hardship this
president made the right choice it was a
delicate balance and he did it exactly
as he should guided by data and we are
far below 2.2 million dead Americans
because of the actions of President
Trump Timothy Kloss Otis wrote quote
conspiracy theorists including most
recently the President of the United
States continue to spread their vile and
misinformation on the platform
disparaging the memory of my wife what I
won't the president give this wood or
piece and stop tweeting about this
conspiracy theory involving his wife why
why can't this litter and get people in
the president I've already asked and
answered this question and our hearts
our hearts our voice our hearts room
with Laurie and I think of the onus on
Joe Scarborough to explain his
interaction with the very matter
Ondine Don Imus his show Chanel the
winner excuse me the winner is talking
specifically with regards to ex CIA
Chief John Brennan how far how willing
are you able to go forward and say that
he lied to the FBI or obstructed justice
in the process of discussing rush
inclusion and the Trump family and on
that note we now have new information
showing that that Obama himself used
foreign intelligence to actually reflect
surveillance on the fifth and 26th floor
of the Trump Tower so to what extent was
John Brennan behind that to what extent
can you share with what with us what you
know yeah John Brennan of all of the
I'll call them bad actors because indeed
they were of the Obama administration
John Brennan probably has the most to
answer because it was John Brennan who
sat before Congress and said the steel
dossier paid for by Hillary Clinton paid
for by the DNC that that document played
no part of the role in opening the
Russia probe when in fact we know it did
when in fact we know it was the impetus
a testified before a FISA Court for its
truthfulness to spy on on the Trump
campaign so John Brennan of all people
probably has more to answer so to to
Samantha power and Susan Rice on these
individuals who admitted under
that they in fact spoke to foreign
leaders and representatives of foreign
leaders during their transition but yet
somehow during the Trump transition that
was uncalled for what has been done all
throughout history was uncalled for and
meriting on masking and meriting
cornering general Lieutenant General
Michael Flynn all of these people have
really legitimate questions to answer I
think we're slowly getting to the bottom
of this but it's a real travesty and
really one of the biggest political
scandals in modern history yes it's
about the the g7 summit so the area
still has a very high number of cases a
prime minister trudeau spoke yesterday
with Chancellor Merkel and president Mac
Hall is the president still confident of
being able to organize the event in like
three weeks it'd be three weeks from now
if we stick to the date it's a really
great question and an important one
because the g7 the president wants to
see this take place as America real
opens as we try to approach a place of
normalcy where people go back to work
where people do recreational activities
but socially distance while they do it
the president thinks no greater example
of reopening I mean this transition to
greatness would be the g7 and the g7
happening here and happening probably
more towards the end of June Robert
O'Brien I believe it was was asked about
this this weekend and Robert O'Brien
said that he's getting a great reception
from world leaders who are asked about
coming we will protect world leaders who
come here just like we protect people in
the White House so we want to see it
happen we think it will happen and so
far foreign leaders are very much on
board with the idea of joining here in
this York and David I don't know if
it'll be the last week of June but
towards the end of June and the goal for
is it is for it to be here at the White
House yep yes right so after the
lowering of the flags this past
does the president have any other plans
in the works to to honor the victims of
the of the virus yeah yeah oh go ahead
sorry and a larger question is does he
see his role as martyr and chief in some
way which would be the traditional role
of president yeah I think he takes that
responsibility very seriously and he
said that this is the hardest part of
his presidency going through this
pandemic he says so many times that he
thinks about many of his friends some of
his friends I should say who have
perished because of this disease it's
real to him it's personal to him it's
why he says you know one death is too
many and he thinks about it all of the
time so he does see his role as that
comforting the nation but reopening the
country giving the country hope at this
time as we look forward to going back to
work and resuming our lives although in
a new reality with new CDC guidelines in
the works
I think lowering the flags is a great
example and we have further
announcements on that front I will be
sure to share those with you yep the
Florida family they have asked the
president that the widower has asked
president in that letter to just dot-com
talking about this and for Twitter to
take down those tweets I just wanted to
ask you is the president asking for
someone for law enforcement to reopen
this cold case is that what defending is
gonna ask the DOJ to reopen something
what is he asking for when he talks
about the cold case yeah I don't have
any future announcements on the
president's action but I would just
refer everyone for those of you who
haven't heard it go back and listen to
the Don Imus soundbite it was very
callous it was very cruel I mean I think
laughing and joking about the death of
an intern is really uncalled for and
that's something we can all agree to
thank you all very much
you
you